[Music]
hey welcome to every damn day two grown
men in their 40s are having a spat on
Instagram and we're going to talk about
Boyd Mayweather jr. you know him he's
that billionaire boxer he posted a 400
word screed attacking 50 cent hey
Ainsley throw up that Instagram post
this is reigniting a longtime feud
between these two guys so you can see
that's four hundred and two words it's
quite a lot I'm trying to wrap my head
around all this Ryan could you recap
what what got us here today so this is
very long this is to recap this has been
from started in 2012 and now we're here
however many years later who can say it
who can say really and basically this is
like a very long post that starts off
with Floyd Mayweather going in because
about like his family as you can see
like his mother it doesn't want to your
son's mother does want to be with you
all this kind of stuff but then it gets
very funny like halfway through where
Floyd is just like attacking all kinds
of stuff here it says you ripped off ja
Rule and that your you stole 50 cents
the real $0.50 story and that you're not
even the real thing a lot of accusation
and then he goes are you this is I'm
gonna read this for you
it goes are you mad that Kanye West
ended your career the only thing you got
going on is power this show that he's on
now and he was the only thing you got
going on is power and everybody watches
that because ghost is a dope-ass
character on the show you can leave the
show everybody will still watch power
but out here in the real world I'm the
real ghost which I think it's great
because he's like I really like your
show what like also screw you it who
loves power so much that you can't bring
himself yeah there's something bad about
that also he says he loves ghosts and he
says I'm the real ghost I think he just
wants to be ghost on part that hurts
here is that they keep bringing up ja
Rule but no one buys the music right
I've never hated ja Rule but he comes up
in every beef yeah his career
still stay this whole thing yeah as
someone who doesn't follow it but
follows the Real Housewives there is a
lot of cross before we get to fifties
response I do want to what is the image
part of this that Floyd has posted go
snitch or die techno snitch or die
Talent so this is a reference to what
that get rid of Curtis Jackson
oh so the album and also supposedly that
he's an informer he's always talking
and like Floyd we know that he's
like he asked for a car back but it's
because he was like out there telling
everybody about it and then also in like
2012 for the original all-star thing
when Lloyd was like apparently they were
like buddies at this time and then Floyd
was like hey let's have a fake beef on
the Internet and then 50 cent was like
this whole thing was fake he asked me to
do it and then I was like what the hell
and that started this whole thing and
then a couple years after that the
reading thing came off it's classic
Bethenny Franklin read but the caption
is so long Aynsley show the next post so
this is a no 50 replied and he points
this out hand yeah it's a definitely a
personal assistant who wrote that was it
I had to do stuff like that all the time
and I was like I like write notes
doctors like you really screwed up and
it was just like oh god like I have to
be responsible like I'm the it just
feels so painful like yelling at someone
through someone else's voice yeah Social
bad for Floyd's personal assistant
verbatim like that's what's so nice
about it because it's just like it gets
so like he's like so quick so quick to
gossip like a bitch why don't you tell
everybody how you got herpes from DJ and
I can imagine who's DJ poor DJ's been
brought into this all they've done is
just had sex with a void mate or with 50
cent so he is gossiping this entire yeah
so I can just imagine the assistant
being like I don't want to bring DJ into
this
one article I read about it said that
there are 49 separate like jabs or
accusations and these in this 400 words
so that's like a jab every ten words is
like N and herpes this is awful this
beast ed like oh yeah in the black
community you've noticed this beef we
ignore it it's like it's like clicked
out and you got a cousin in the heart
than just a vicar and he's like it's not
him sitting over there let him sit next
to the liquor and they'll be they'll
figure it out it'll be like that goofy
where's the album rule was like EDM of
rap it was one song one song our rule is
the EDM a brass hear me out here all
this so accepted exactly the same and it
just blended together just like EDM
music you don't know what a general song
would off it came on and you're and
you're rooting for another album yes
there's one other thing I want to point
out in fifties response so he includes
you know the crying Floyd but then we've
got this hashtag there at the bottom lay
chemin du roi did a little research this
is a champagne that 50 cent is selling
so is this all just fake just to get to
this hashtag so there's people like me
look up what that is exactly I know that
50 cent has a champagne we knew about
house since 2012 we like they'll figure
it out we've been dealt with them both
just money Mayweather is known for
promoting 50 Cent's is known for
promotion pink if all five of us fought
Floyd at the same time could we win no
maybe we have Forks if we all had one he
has a great history
a very long history of beating up both
bit men and women the bubbly for your
beef would go like this one of us would
get punched in the face four of us would
be scared and then one of us would get
punched in the face three of us would be
scared and it would just keep going
until the Brit until it was over
okay well let us know what you think in
the comments hey Natasha what else do we
have going on in the YouTube community
section today that's right so today in
the YouTube community section we're
gonna post asking you to tell us which
Bruce Willis character we should dress
up as for our Thursday episode where we
will dress up as Bruce Willis characters
based on what you say so Wow our fate is
in your head and why are we doing that
oh well we're doing that because we're
celebrating the roast of Bruce Willis
which will be on Comedy Central that's
right July 29th coming up so let us know
you could say Bruce wills character or
maybe just a fun character from a Bruce
Willis movie I don't know get creative
we're gonna do a different thing right
now I don't like to do laundry not
because I'm lazy but because I believe
underwear is best for in stinky if I do
Secret Santa my gift to you is a painful
secret from my pack
I always choose self-checkout because I
like to make the robots yell hey as you
might have noticed sweet little Jordan
wasn't with us during the discussion
today that's because he was in San Diego
for comic-con where he was pitching some
ideas he has four new superheroes give
this a watch
pika pika Pikachu Pikachu Comic Con
Pikachu got Pikachu pika how many Comic
Cons has this thing for you guys
27 for me and I'll wait what are you
looking forward to seeing in real life
who is blue my mom oh wow
very good to meet you this is all her
idea
[Music]
that was really cool you control your
mom with just like that they're no
different than say a dog moms are no
different than dogs you said it so all
these superhero bitches that I wrote I'm
wondering if you guys could maybe like
give me your thoughts on them and like
whether or not you'd buy or pass on the
ideas so the first one is Power Man he's
super strong and he has all the powers
out there and he kills the villain right
away there's nothing it's just kills
building every episode what does power
man's like end goal besides killing
billions all right but I think you want
to say bye we got one bot he kills
pedophiles and he files them down with a
nail filer so it takes a very long time
would probably show would be lit it's
kind of a perfect hook I mean unless
you're pro pedophile you may want to
change the name like the like the
pedophile hunter no actually that sounds
worse I want to see if you guys can
guess the powers of these next guys now
you know Supergirl what is super hot
girl her looks melt your face off so I
had all sexes it's a little sexist
Pikachu he's really like covered in
flames bingo dad tell your son to get
his mind out of the gutter he's thinking
watching too much porn do you ever walk
in on him in the in the costume
masturbating yeah
he handles his his tentacles quite a bit
he handles his what all right Chinaman
keep in mind I am part Chinese
is a superhero that collects very fine
china
he breaks it's really good at making
like puffs I'm assuming it's to kill men
with Chinese plates some do this cutlery
or plate plate spinning I try to get out
of the plate he's really small okay
don't be racist I'm part Chinese he's
not really small we're normal-sized
people China man's powers he's really
good at math and he's bad at driving
venom do not tell me about my culture
what do you think soul cycler does soul
cycler is a villain who convinces people
that $34.00 is an okay price for a spin
class oh my god yeah alright this last
one is Comedy Central's Jordan Mendoza
what do you think this guy's power
awesome interview an amazing superpower
I'm Jordan Mendoza needs his own show on
Comedy Central can you do the thing
where you took me and then I was just
kidding
sweet little Jordan at comic-con should
I stop calling him sweet little Jordan
do you think maybe because he's a 28
year old man but he is sweet little
Jordan I liked when he is talking to
Pikachu in that video that we just
watched yeah okay great mm-hmm we have
to blur out Pikachu no because we don't
make the video all about Pikachu Pikachu
is just one of many characters we
featured by talking about Pikachu now
may be becoming increasingly problematic
but I think we're good I think we're in
the player I think we're in the clear so
you should we should call that cheer
Pikachu that nigga's head off the
Pikachu no it's very good one time I saw
an Elmo vomit of Elmo's with their heads
off is like the saddest day of my life
over the next one every day I'm dead
[Music]
you